all right so we have uh our last talk
will be an
hour long talk from ahmed el away
just down the road at stanford thank you
very much ryan
and thank you for uh the organization
and for inviting me to give this talk
as i said so my bandwidth is somewhat
limited so i'll cut my video and
hopefully
don't feel offended if i do that um okay
so
i'll be talking about uh incremental
approximate message passing and this is
after
some work of andre mozanari that was
published in 2018 and then a follow-up
work
of myself andrea and mark selke uh two
years
to two years later so here um and by the
way please let me know if you have any
questions or anything
i'll try to go slow so that's why i
chose to do this
on an ipad so the question here the
general question is to
try to optimize
uh random
functions
on let's say the hypercube plus minus
one
power no we do not actually see your
screen updating i assume from the
clicking you're writing
uh let's see so yes um so far i only see
the title and
uh the subheading i see your mouse
cursor moving around though
uh so there maybe there is a problem in
the connection of my ipad with my
so sometimes just if you're using
notability just getting out and
in works ah
let's try this again
it doesn't show up still we don't see
anything new besides the title this is
this is embarrassing let's see i'm gonna
pause the sharing and i'm gonna do it
again
[Music]
nothing still okay this is weird
uh let's see how do i stop sharing
stop share share again
[Music]
okay so my technology is really failing
me um
i apologize for this no worries
right so my ipad cannot connect it
doesn't want to connect at all
um
ahmed is there a program that you can
use on your desktop
uh that you're gonna be using i do have
i do have slides so as as a last resort
i'll just uh just abandon trying to do
this on ipad and do slides but uh
okay are you connecting via airplay or
what
yeah i'm trying to do airplay right
yeah he's just not finding it for some
reason
okay let's try again
yeah i think i'm gonna do slides um let
me try to find my slice now
yeah apologies let's see
please go take a break and get coffee
this will take a couple of minutes
rights
okay
should work now
do you see my slice
yes we see your slides yes great okay
so i apologize for this that's uh all
right
um so this will be uh this will be a
talk about
optimization and midfield spin glasses
so
uh this is joint work with andrea
montanari and mark silke
and uh so don't pay attention to this uh
this was not intended
these slides were not intended to be
presented in this workshop but it will
do the work
um right so uh
the objective here is to try to optimize
highly non-complex and combinatorial
functions in polynomial time and the
second
related question is that of sampling
from high dimensional distributions
and uh is that possible in general
and so there are numerous applications
in all computationally oriented fields
of course and we've heard
uh very related questions uh about this
in previous talks toxin this morning and
the idea here is to study a simple model
from theoretical physics which exhibits
a very
rich structure and try to exploit that
structure hopefully
in order to design algorithms
okay so so the the first
part of the talk is to actually define
these functions
and so generally these will be what are
called the easily mixed pin
mixed p spins hamiltonians and in
general so we define them as being
a centered so we have hnb in the
hamiltonian or the function that we're
trying to optimize it's defined over the
hypercube sigma n
and it's a centered gaussian process
with covariance that is when you
evaluate it at two a point sigma and
sigma prime
is just a function of the inner products
between these two functions
at these two points right and the
covariance is completely characterized
by
this function sigma or c
and so we could write it explicitly so
either we can do a definition
of this form this h is a centered
gaussian process with this covariance or
we can write it explicitly point wise
and this is the expression for it so wp
is a tensor symmetric gaussian tensor
that is of order p
and sigma p is just the rank one p order
tensor of sigma and this is just the
inner products between tensors right
and so the relationship between the
function
c and the coefficient cp is that c is
just the generating function of these
coefficients
okay two examples to keep in mind
are the two splinter the assurance in
kirkpatrick hamiltonian which is just a
quadratic here so this is
just depends on product sigma i sigma j
and these coefficients are gaussian
and random and xc in this case is just x
squared
and the second example i want you to
keep in mind is the three spin model
which is almost the same thing but
here we have polynomials of degree three
okay and these are still
gaussian uh gij are still gaussian okay
and now so the question here would be to
uh
maximize uh this this function this
random function
over the hypercube so this is called the
ground state as a jargon
okay um so how can we efficiently find
an approximate ground states but so
first i have to tell you what is the
model the computational model that i
have
that i that i'm considering here i'm
considering a model in which uh there's
an oracle that gives me gradients so
either if you're in the two-spin
case if you're in the insurance and
perpetrator case you don't have to think
too much about this
i just give you the random matrix of
interactions and i ask you to
produce a good solution but in general
you
need a description a concise description
of this hn because it's a general
function
and in particular i'll just consider
that an
oracle gives me gradients at any point i
want okay
and i have a tolerance epsilon and i
want to generate
a vector sigma alg that depends on all
the queries that i get from the
from the oracle and for which i have a
one minus epsilon multiplicative
approximation to the maximum with high
probability
and i want the number of queries to be
polynomial in n and one over epsilon
okay okay so in general if i don't
assume anything
then this problem is already np hard if
you don't i don't assume that
my function h is random this is already
for quadratic it's np hard
and it's np hard already for very bad
approximation ratios if
one minus epsilon is already of order
one over log n to some power
this is uh impossible this is not
feasible
and um okay so one can consider for
instance convex relaxations in the
general
and then in the non in the average case
you can consider convex relaxation so
for instance let's consider the
quadratic case which is the case k equal
to so this is just the schrodingent
kirkpatrick model
and i try to compute this maximum this
maximum will be of order 1.52
this is uh i'll talk about this a bit
later this is called the parisi formula
and so one can do a spectral relaxation
so we talked about relaxations in
dysphoria
and for this particular problem if you
just compute the spectral electrician
which is
uh just relaxes the sphere relaxes the
hypercube by the sphere of the same
radius
then this will be just the first
eigenvalue of this matrix of g which is
two
right so it misses by a constant factor
the optimal value
and um okay so the next one
is the sdv relaxations which has been
discussed this morning
i just put this sigma to the other side
and so i have g times sigma sigma
transpose and i replace sigma sigma
transpose by sppsd matrix
that is n by n and has diagonal being
the identity so one
one's on the diagonal turns out that
this doesn't improve and we've discussed
this this morning
and so it turns out so now you can
consider the general hierarchy of sdp
relaxations of
sls relaxations it turns out that degree
4 sls
doesn't do any better than this uh
number two it still gives you the
the same value and there is strong
evidence that
uh that's uh this is the spectral bounds
this
number two is the best computationally
possible for certification of reputation
so here i'm considering convex
relaxations that are by definition will
always give you a
upper bound whether g is uh random or
not but you want for g
being random or coming from the goe to
be the closest possible so this is
called
certification turns out that this
problem is quite hard or is believed to
be quite hard and the
spectral bound is the best possible
conjecturally okay so further approaches
uh you can consider now the spherical
case so let's relax this uh boolean
uh constraints with plus minus one
constraint and just consider it a
spherical case
but now let's consider a homogeneous
homogeneous uh
degree k polynomial so which is called
the pure case spin spherical model
and you can consider also the sos
hierarchy at level k so you match the
degree of the polynomial in your
hierarchy
and it turns out this is not only
greater than the optimum but it's
greater than the optimum by a diverging
factor which is polynomial in
n so this is like when you start to
consider higher order polynomials this
doesn't do any better it
gets strictly worse so other approaches
that you can consider a global dynamic
so let's move away from convex
relaxation then let's consider
for instance other other other
approaches and here for instance you can
do
uh launch valve global dynamics there is
a rich literature but we
know that at least at low temperature
there is little dynamics are slow and
mixing is exponential and
typically in uh polynomial time you'll
only get stuck in what's called the
threshold energy
so this is an energy that is yeah i i i
meant sorry
um this better prologue swami gurswami
lee
yeah the left-hand side of that
inequality
is the bound on the hamiltonian achieved
by
any constant level of sos that's what
that means
so this is uh sos at level k right
this k is level k yeah so i'm just
matching
i'm considering the same level as the
degree of the polynomial i'm considering
i'm trying to optimize ah but so this is
getting
worse with k relative to the optimum
because you're increasing you're
simultaneously increasing
the arity of the model as well as the uh
okay so you can consider k fix
and uh just let n go to infinity then
you'll see that's
already and it gets bad right
yeah um
okay i'm just wondering what's known
about if we hold the arity of the model
fixed while increasing the degree of sos
uh yeah so i'm not sure this i'm not
absolutely sure if this has been
analyzed but i might i might
i don't know the literature so well in
this in this field maybe that has been
done it has 2016. yeah do you know
well so this uh this basically
paper contains a bound and also um
the joint work of uh rather than going
to teach
on myself as an upper ground but you
don't get any of the constant level so
as you don't get any improvement over
this
i see there's also at least a proof
sketch or
some would call it a proof of a matching
lower bound for the case of degree
three lower bounds uh degree three s
degree three polynomials
uh high degree sos like degree uh
end of the 0.01 um
in a paper from fox 17.
i see well thank you guys for that for
that hopefully that answers chris's
question
um all right let's continue here so
so the type of algorithms i will try to
discuss today are
what i call dual algorithms and that
will show up in a second we'll be clear
in a second so
there's a very nice paper by iran subway
that considers the spherical model
so consider all piece pins and make
mixed piece pins for
when you're not considering optimizing
over the hypercube but over the sphere
of the same radius and he has this
iterative algorithm that that is based
on this
idea of orthogonal updates that tries to
find an optimum
and it indeed tries to succeed that's
getting
an approximate uh optimizer that is one
minus epsilon optimal for any epsilon
positive
and the algorithm runs in polynomial
time and andrea
afterwards uh i tried to extend this
idea to the easing phase for the sk
model
and the same result holds and these both
of these results
hold under a certain condition that is
called an overlap gap assumption
um so under this overlap gap you can get
optimum
approximate optima for any epsilon but
on the other side uh there is a very
nice line of work by gamma nick and his
co-authors in many papers that show
impossibility results if there is
overlap gap
so if the problem has overlapped gap
then there is a large
class of algorithms that provably fail
in this uh
in this for this type of questions
okay so let me tell you about um
uh what we can do about this problem so
i have to tell you what the parisi
formula is so
that what the crazy formula
characterizes the
maximum value that is achieved uh for
this
particular optimization problem and i
need to introduce it to you so
let u be the set of functions that are
go from the interval zero one to the
positive reals there are none decreasing
under l1
okay so now take a function from
from this class and put it here in this
pde
this is a nonlinear pde that you can
solve backwards from this terminal
condition
and now solve this pde and consider this
functional p of gamma
that takes the value at 0 0 and then
subtracts a linear term in gamma
so this is a functional over this class
u
and now the results is that the
normalized maximum
over uh the hypercube of this random
function
h converges to the infimum
of p over this class u okay so this is
called the parisi formula at zero
temperature
and uh so the first stain so okay so
this seems to come out of nowhere
first the second thing is that the
maximum
flips into an enthemum so how did that
happen we didn't change signs or
anything here in an obvious way so how
did the maximum flip into an in femur
and the question another question is how
does this
discrete problem converge to something
that is so complicated that it has to be
written in terms of a pde
non-linear pde and an impediment over a
class of functions it's a variational
problem over a class of functions
so okay so let me describe just a rough
picture of the landscape here so if you
consider
the super level sets of the hamiltonian
that are uh one minus epsilon above the
what times the that times the optimum
and consider sampling two points from
the uniform distribution over
the sets so that's so now we consider
the
inner products the normalized inner
products between these two uh
configurations it turns out that that
will converge to a non-degenerate random
variable
so this random variable will not
concentrate and it turns out that we'll
have a full distribution that has a
certain support that is non-trivial
and this is in very sharp contracts
contrast with convex functions so indeed
you have a convex function and you uh
consider the level set or the super
level set at any level epsilon that will
be a convex
set the uniform measure over convex set
will be lock concave therefore it will
enjoy a certain amount of concentration
and this inner product will indeed
concentrate for a convex function
so this is very much the opposite of a
convex function so
pictorially we can see something that
looks like this can i jump in with a
quick clarifying question
yeah please so is this the convergence
is this
uh conjectural or it's i'm just trying
to understand what state of the art is
in
right so for certain models uh for
certain
there are certain technical conditions
under which you can show that this thing
converges to uh
to uh well gasol guy talks about
dispersing formula and gamma has a
probabilistic interpretation in that
gamma at least at positive temperature
gamma is actually the cumulative
distribution function of this random
variable
or at least that's the physical
intuition or interpretation of gamma
and uh under certain technical
conditions you can show that indeed
this uh this random variable will have a
distribution that converges to gamma but
i don't remember exactly the technical
conditions i think
it's generic generic models that it's a
certain condition on the
on the generating uh function c that
defines the covariance but i don't
exactly remember which what are the
conditions there
yeah does this answer your question yeah
i was just trying to understand
this is this uh it's subsequently
converging because these are bounded uh
bounded quantities i'm just trying to
understand which cases the convergence
is n goes to infinities
understood you said there are some
technical conditions under which this is
known okay
yeah that's right and uh yeah so
yeah of course these are bounded so you
have subsequent conversions anyway but
you can show that the whole sequence
converges to this thing that is
gamma that is the minimizer under
certain conditions
yeah thanks so there is uh
so for the algorithm for the sake of
this algorithm we're gonna
uh exploits this uh the celebrated
structure that is called the ultrametric
structure that that is that organizes
uh the the optima or the approximate
global optima of this hamiltonian and
this has been discovered by physicists
and has been
progressively better understood by
mathematicians so
here we have um a tree so you can
picture a tree that has a roots
and then branches infinitely often and
this picture
is as follows so this is related to a
problem in the following sensing that
the clusters of near optima
in the hypercube are represented by the
leaves of this infinitary tree so you
have
the leaves of this tree represent the
clusters of neural optima
and the ancestral nodes in this tree
which are nodes that are at
level at this level frame sorry at this
level for instance
those are associated to points and that
are inside the solid cube
and at level c so we're here we're
indexing this tree by an interval from
zero to one
and at level t of that tree the norm of
the points that is
inside the cube that is at that level
has normality when
properly normalized okay
and now the euclidean distance between
clusters if you check
to look at this cluster and this cluster
by the way do you guys see my cursor
right
yeah yes um if you take uh the inner
product or the distance between this
this point and this points then their
inner products or their distance is
reflected by the tree uh distance
industry so you have to go up here and
then come back to get to understand the
distance so they're organized in a
in a in an ultrametric way in a
tree-like structure
hey i'm ed quick question so um i only
know the physics version of this
so it is the is the reason why these
states
these nodes are associated with points
in the interior of the cube
are those are the coordinates the
marginals of uh
a given of each spin within that cluster
right so
yeah there is there is a more refined
description which is to say that
actually these are clusters that are
okay so the clusters are uh
they have this hierarchical clustering
uh uh
structure to them and the point m is the
very center of the corresponding
cluster at that level right so m is just
the magnetization or is that the mean
of the of that cluster right so that's
that's uh what do you say
when you say marginals that's what what
marginal means in this case
so right so this uh structure has been
has been discovered and indeed studied
to extensive detail
in this uh seminal paper from 1985
it's called the ultimate the
microstructure of ultra metricity by
masala and diazo and in that paper they
say the following they say that the
ultrametric topology of the space of
equilibrium states that a spring glass
deserves special attention such an
organization might might exist in other
systems with frustration and disorder
and it should have consequences in such
fields like optimization problems and
neural networks
so so far so after the publication of
that paper it hasn't been
uh very much elucidated this
disconnection that has been foreseen in
this paper hasn't been elucidated
and this has been now uh exploited in
the last past couple
of years by people like uh subhag and uh
andrea and then uh with our paper that
follows up on them
so here the main algorithmic idea is to
start at the root of this tree
and to construct a random path that just
travels and explores this tree up to a
certain point where it hits the leaf and
hopefully that leaf will be the optimum
so that's the main algorithmic idea
so the geometric picture the associated
geometric picture here is to start at
the origin
of rn and to grow a certain path a
random path
that travels in the cube inside the cube
and hopefully
at the terminal time it'll hit the
corner of the cube so we'll have to
steer this uh
this this trajectory in the right way so
this will come up to be a
stochastic control problem that i'll
talk about later
okay so the main result here is that
there exists an algorithm
that outputs a sigma that is in the cube
after c of epsilon iterations
so the iterations is the number of
conversations with the article
the number of gradient evaluations so
that's such that you get one minus
epsilon times
the infimum of p which is supposed to
describe the maximum of the hamiltonian
but here we're optimizing over a
slightly larger class of functions that
is that i call
l and this class of functions contain
non-monotone functions so it's not so
you only contain non-decreasing
functions but l can contain
functions that are decreasing and then
increasing
and it turns out this l if you intersect
l with the set of non-decreasing
functions you get u
so that's that's the relationship
between u and l
uh so of course if this minimizer is
achieved at a non-decreasing function
then then you've you've reached the goal
right so
the pro the algorithm is optimal so it
reaches one minus epsilon times the
optimum
if the infimum is achieved at a
non-decreasing function
that's just an obvious observation here
and so the fact that uh the
property that that's in femum is
strictly increasing
is what we call the overlapping gap
condition or physics physicists call it
full or continuous replica symmetry
breaking
so that's by definition we take as a
definition of an overlap gap
the property that this in theme is
optimized at a function that is strictly
increasing
does this make sense yeah ahmed i
remember from andrea's paper that you
know he kind of assured us that the
physicists believe that no overlap got
properly
a property so i mean is this a more
generalized version but also
like strongly believed no so uh
right so it depends on the model that
you're considering for the sheraton
kirkpatrick model it is indeed believes
that there is an overlap gap
but for other models for instance just
the three-spin model when you consider a
polynomial of degree three
there is an overlapping at least it is
believed that there is an overlap gap
and uh will show that this indeed so the
algorithm will not be able to achieve
the optimum it'll just achieve this
value but not more
actually in b equal to four there is a
provable over that gap
for p equals four uh i'm not aware of
that for that for that
the hypercube case for the the type
worked out the computations actually i
see interesting i would like to see it
i did not know that thanks
um right okay so
not only does this algorithm achieve
this value but
also this is this value is the best
possible achievable by a class of what
we call imp algorithms so this is
this hints at an algorithmic threshold
for optimization and speed analysis
so we consider this class of algorithms
that we can it's a
there are many degrees of freedom in
this class and
the best value that is achieved in this
class is given
by this number
i'm sorry can you just this went by too
quickly for me what is
uh u was the set of
sorry what is l now yeah so you went by
very fast
right so sorry yeah so the infimum over
of p over the class u is what describes
the ground state energy is that the
maximum
right and and you're saying that it's an
infimum over a larger class
l which is therefore less than or equal
to and if these are different then
you have a gap but can you remind me
what l the set l is again
so i didn't define this properly i
didn't i don't have any uh
formula for the set l on my slides but i
just say that it contains
so u is it is defined primarily by the
property that's it the functions that's
that it contains are non-decreasing
but okay perhaps i met you can say l is
just functions that have
bounded total variation in any sub
interval of zero one
so basically any function that is not
too
too wild crazy yeah and so the line of
this slide what you mean is that l
contains non-monotone functions yeah
okay
not that it's subset u does okay yeah
yeah yeah thank you
and this is the kind of like whether
this uh gap exists or not is something
that you can kind of
try to test with the computer uh it's
not the basis of
some of the the beliefs about it right
so that's the my next slide
let's see okay so let's test this in a
computer
um you can solve this for sk so for the
two-spin model you can minimize this for
easy formula and this is the gamma that
that minimizes the freezing formula okay
so it's strictly increasing at least
according to my discretization
and uh so you see that there is an
overlap gap so we i do actually believe
that there is an overlap gap
and in this case so the optimal value is
the
is the one that is achieved by our
algorithm which is given by this number
so for the three spin model so this is
very different
so if you solve the problem over u which
is the set of functions that are
non-decreasing there is a plateau
and then the function diverges
and the ground state energy is given by
this number that is point h1
on the other hand if you solve the
extended variational principle over this
larger class
l there is uh so we see that gamma will
look like this more or less so gamma
will be decreasing and then
increasing and this is very far from
being not decreasing of course
and the that therefore the algorithmic
value is strictly smaller than 0.81 it's
about 0.8 0.800 okay
so there is a gap and
moreover so i want to compare this also
to the threshold energy which is the
value that is believed to be achieved by
global dynamics
at least over polynomially many steps or
constantly many steps
and that value has been evaluated based
on physics grounds
in a paper by tommaso rizzo and that
value is about 0.78
so it's strictly smaller than the value
that is achieved by our algorithm
so which means that this algorithm is
actually better than doing
caliber dynamics
okay so let me tell you but by the way
amid is the graph on the left
just the tail of the graph on the right
uh the graph on the left
is the tail of the gravel it looks like
if you
yeah i mean they look
qualitatively they look the same at
least on the
close to one but i wouldn't be able to
say that they're actually equal
i guess like one point it's like the
graph on the right is not like the cdf
of any random variable
exactly but that's the point yeah it's
so yeah so um
yeah so the graph on the left it's the
cdf of a probability distribution which
is
okay so but it corresponds to a
probability measure
but the graph on the right is just
assigned a measure it's not a
probability measure
so let me tell you about this algorithm
so this is a general class of algorithms
that are called amp
and um right so the general
iteration is as follows so you
initialize it so there are two main
iterates that i call m
and z so these are the main domain
objects
and you initialize them in a certain way
then you'll consider a class of
functions the sequence of functions
fl that take the first letter so you
have a sequence of functions that you
can choose however you want
now up to step l you evaluate
this function on the true z zero up to
zl and that gives you ml
now you ask you give this vector ml to
your oracle
computes the gradient for you gives you
this number this vector that is the
gradients
and then subtracts a linear combination
of the previous ends to obtain the next
z okay sorry okay
so that's the algorithm and these
numbers these coefficients of
closed form you can compute them it's
not a problem so i didn't put a formula
for them but
yeah so there is you can you can
characterize the behavior of this
algorithm
in in a vast generality so it doesn't
matter what these functions are as long
as they're lip sheets and they're
weakly differentiable that's that's fine
so you can characterize
uh the sequence of errors z zero up to
zl for any fixed
l and this will converge this
tuple will converge to a certain
centered gaussian process with a
covariance
that is given by this so that this tuple
will converge to
random variables that are z here so
these are these are scalars
these are vectors so what i mean by
convergence here is that the empirical
distributions of the entries will
converge to a random variable that is
real valued
and the stochastic process that they
converge to is a gaussian vector that is
centered and has a covariance that is
defined recursively by this formula
okay
so just as an example if you consider
the quadratic case where we just have a
quadratic here
um then the gradient is just g so we're
just multiplying g by
m here instead of the gradient and
c prime is the identity or c prime of x
is x
in which case we have this relationship
in the covariance
okay
so just sorry i just want to make sure
that i'm oriented properly so
i should think of f is not depending on
g f is the sequence of functions that
are deterministic
okay yeah so the randomness comes from
disease
not there's nothing there's nothing g
related here
and what's what's that from the
initialization review
yeah so the initialization will be
chosen in a certain way that i explained
but that's also independence of g
okay thank you so so if we wanted to do
simple gradient descent
then ml would be equal to
zl is that right or yeah so so so this
this looks like it includes standard
gradient descent but it also includes
fancy things that have momentum
terms and things like that yeah fair
enough yes uh
that's one way to see it right so here
i'm so
for gradient essentially would remember
power iteration for instance you would
remove this term
or the last term the reaction term and
then m would be z
right but here you don't have to do that
this is a more general iteration
um so here okay so for quadratics
for quadratics you can write down so
these these coefficients
okay so once but one special case is um
when f the function f doesn't depend on
the whole tuple it depends only on the
last point zl
in which case that the this this
iteration simplifies
and then the reaction term this term
that i subtract reduces to only one
one one term instead of having l terms
and uh so it looks like this so this is
perhaps more more
more familiar you're perhaps more
familiar with the usual amp iteration
which is this one
um right so if you can write it in
coordinates this is what it looks like
um so i was planning to explain um
the the the role of this of this this uh
this term this reaction term here and
basically the idea
is the role of this memory term is to
replace yet any iteration every
iteration to replace
g to act as if g was replaced by a new
copy
at every iteration so basically suppose
now that
this term doesn't exist but at every
iteration of the algorithm
i get a new g that is independent of
everything else
so suppose that that's the case then if
i compute the inner products between zl
plus one and zj
plus one so for l different from j
possibly
so since this is a new iteration i get a
new g
that is independent from m on both sides
here and here
right so now i can by concentration of
measure over g
which is independent of everything else
this is reduces to the inner products
between
ml and mj right
so what the algorithm does so of course
the algorithm
does not have access to new randomness
at every iteration
it has to use the same matrix over and
over again which creates a dependence
between m
and g so this argument is no longer
valid i cannot
i cannot use this alg this this this
arguments to argue that's the
inner products between diseases it's the
same as the inner products between the
ends
but the reaction term here this this
memory term acts as
f so it restores this property so it
basically removes all the dependencies
in order to
still make this thing work this
relationship work and that's exactly the
contents of state evolution
which means that okay so the inner
products between disease is the same as
the inner products between the ends and
recall that
m is just f l of this this tuple
so this is a very high level of
explanation of the
presence of this memory term
um perhaps i should just uh
not talk about the heuristic here about
the derivation of this memory term
so one this is not a difficult one that
you can do
that's um okay
so there is a rigorous uh proof of the
state evolution
that has been uh uh considered or
invented by baltihouse by erwin
balthazin that is called gusting
condition and this relies on the
on the assumption that g's are the
interaction terms the interaction
coefficients
are gaussian and uh so this this is a
certain proof that is very dependent on
the gaussian nature of the interactions
but you would expect universality in
this case so so here
amp shouldn't really depend or the
behavior of amp shouldn't really depend
on whether the interactions are gaussian
or
have another distribution as long as
they're iid you have
finite moments etc and so you would want
to extend the proof of state evolution
or the correctness of state evolution to
non-gaussian matrices and indeed that's
this is what it's what's called
universality
and this has been proved by bayati
montenaria and for
a certain class restricted class of
functions fl
and those are polynomials to be more
precise they proved this for polynomial
for polynomial non-linearities and
recently in a very nice beautiful work
by chen and lam they extended this
to all lipschitz functions so your fl
can be any liquids function
and you still have universality
okay so let's go back to optimization so
now i introduced this whole
uh class of algorithms and you can tune
the files however you want
in order to get an algorithm so how do
we choose these non-linearities
so there's this idea of orthogonal
updates that we we're gonna we're gonna
use here so
so optimizing over the class of files is
somewhat intractable it's too large of a
class to optimize over explicitly but so
we're going to use an idea here
uh that introduces the following
constraints so this is due to eliran
tsubak
and the idea here is to choose the
functions f
in order for the increments in the m's
so ml plus 1 minus
ml to be orthogonal in the past to the
past iterates
okay so this is the new ingredients that
i'm introducing
so state evolution would that will imply
since since i have
the g the the disease have the same
covariance as the m's
this will imply that also these have
this
uh property of orthogonal updates
right but these are gaussians so we have
a gaussian a sequence of gaussian
vectors which are centered
and they have orthogonal increments so
we can
in particular choose to make them be
brownian motion
okay so this is of course sample of
discrete time surrounding motion that is
sampled
it's three times discrete times of the
iteration of the algorithm
okay so now once uh we want these to be
brownian motions and i'll just
initialize them by consistency i'll just
initialize the first
iterates to be gaussian also with a
certain covariance with certain variants
now my m i'm going to put different
first this anzac
that my m will look would take this form
so
it depends on the difference in the
increments or the increments in z
times a function u g or u j that only
depends
on the the first j errors of the
of the sequence z so it looks like a
martingale here so we have a bunch of
terms that are that are that are uh
orthogonal
and now i'm reducing the choice if this
non-linearity is f
to the choice of this nonlinearity is u
j
so this is a choice that i made
okay now it turns out that i can analyze
the
i can analyze the behavior of this
algorithm i can analyze the
energy that is achieved or the value
that is achieved by this algorithm
okay um so basically there is a
constraint
on these functions uj that arises from
from the algorithm so i cannot have any
uj i want there is a constraints that i
have to
implement and basically that constraint
is that's the second moment if you j has
to be one for all j
so that comes from the brownian nature
of the or the orthogonal uh
increments uh constraints of of the
algorithm so basically
if you assume that the algorithm
produces a brownian emotion up to time t
and you want to show that it
produces cell and a brownian motion up
to time t plus one
you have to verify the conditions of the
brownian motion which is the independent
increments and that
each increment has variance that is
delta and that will imply necessarily
that this
this condition has to hold
okay so now one thing that i can do also
is to try to analyze the value that is
achieved by this algorithm so m
my m is the the hopefully the number
the the vector that will i will output
at the end of the iteration so i'll do a
certain number of iterations
and then i'll put a vector m hopefully
that will be close to the corner of the
hypercube
and i want to analyze the value that is
achieved by this algorithm
so still using state evolution and this
is a computation that one can do it's
not a difficult one
you can analyze uh the limit of this
this value and that will converge to
this integral to the expectation of this
integral
where you here you basically is becomes
a stochastic process instead of
considering discrete time
thing you can lets delta the
discretization go to zero and then you
get a stochastic process instead of
having a discrete
process okay
so the value that i achieve is this i
have a constraint
which is the second moment of view has
to be one for all times
and i'm adding another constraints which
is really uh
just capturing the facts that i want uh
my my iterators to converge to a corner
of the cube
which is the fact that i'm in an easing
case so since my m
will hopefully converge to a corner of
the cube m at time one or its limits in
this sense in this scaling limit which i
call capital m
at time one you can write it like this
has to be between minus one and one
or more precisely it has to be uh
included in the minus v minus one or one
but you can relax it to the
this interval almost surely
are there any questions here so far
perhaps more than a question a little
remark that
yeah perhaps can be useful there is this
orthogonality constraint that plays an
important role that is the
the algorithm always move by moving
orthogonal to the current position
right and this is you know the the
fundamental inspiration to this
is you know the work of uh you know
physicists dating back to you know
parisi meza etc
that says that this tree that you draw
you know in your slide if you embed it
in the hyper cube
is such that each node
branches in a way orthogonal to the
position of the node so each node is
embedded
from a point to a point in the cube ml
and the branching are orthogonal to this
right so that suggests the idea that
you know was was exploited by you know
eliran
very nicely to follow this right
right so yeah i didn't describe the
whole picture there's a very
detailed understanding of what this tree
looks like and the structure this
microstructure of ultrametricity is
and this has indeed been foreseen by
physicists this idea of orthogonal
updates has been first seen by
physicists
but that's what we're exploiting here
um all right so let me go back here so
now this becomes an algorithmic design
question
right so i have a class of algorithms
that are parameterized by these
functions u
and i know for each choice of the
functions you
i know what the what the energy uh what
what energy i achieved by this algorithm
in this
limit now i want to maximize this number
i want the u's that maximize this number
according to these constraints
right so this becomes a stochastic
control problem
so a maximizing over process is you that
has that are in a certain space
that that is nice and everything there
are technical conditions there
the main conditions are that the second
moment is always one
and that's this integral this brownian
this this ito integral is between minus
and
one and one at the last time at time one
okay so now i can i can try to analyze
this and just try to get what is the
value e star here i can try to analyze
this
okay so this is the main the main the
main the main problem this is you see
this is a linear function in u
this is a non-convex function this is a
non-convex constraint this is also more
or less a convex constraints
this is the problematic constraint so
i'll try to relax it
okay so let's try to relax it so i'll
try to put that constraint
in the objective function i'll just
multiply it by lagrangian multiplier
this lagrangian multiplier call it new
here so i'm just putting the constraints
this is the usual thing you would do
with a convex optimization or a
non-convex optimization problem
when you relax it you put the
constraints in the objective function
and you multiply it by a
by a multiplier and that multiplier i
wrote it here in a very convenient way
in terms of this function gamma that is
that is that
it is related the name gamma is not
fortuitous
it is related to the prezi formula in a
second
so this becomes a convex problem
uh that i can try to study that i can
try to analyze
and just our remark is that since this
is a relaxation i have that my e star is
always smaller not no larger than
the value of this relaxation for any
gamma for any choice of gamma
okay now the theorem is that that's this
relaxation
is the parisi functional so this is one
of the main theorems here
so the breezy functional that i showed
you in
maybe 10 slides ago that can be written
in terms of a functional
over a solution of a nonlinear pde it
can be equivalently written
as this stochastic control problem
okay second this inequality
can turn into equality if you optimize
so this is
this you have an inequality so in
particular you can put an infimum here
over a large enough class of functions
and if this function this class of
functions is large enough this
inequality becomes tight so you can you
can you can saturate this integral
this duality gap by choosing the class
of functions over which you're
optimizing to be large enough
right and this is what this is so it
turns out that this class of function is
what i call
script l and that script l doesn't have
to
be restricted to the class of increasing
or non-decreasing functions
it can be any function that is nice
enough that is not too crazy
okay so i'm saturating this duality gap
by optimizing optimizing over a function
of
classic functions that is large enough
so now we're done right so i have a
value
that is the value that is achieved by my
algorithm or the best value that could
be achievable
in my class of algorithms that i call
e-star to be equal to the parisi formula
albeit this the the space over which i'm
optimizing is slightly larger
are there any questions
okay so maybe i can tell you a little
bit about the proof but um this this
uh this will be a very high level so let
me tell you about the proof that this
relaxation
is the pretty formula so this is a
stochastic control problem and this
is the breezy for the functional that
has been defined
using the non-linear pde
so i will consider this function that i
call v
and this function has been cooked up in
a certain way so it depends on two
parameters
time and a position a position variable
that i call c
and um this is almost the same thing as
in the definition of this relaxation
except
that i'm only starting the integral at
time t instead of time zero
and i am so in all of these integrals
i'm starting at time t
and here in the constraint i'm adding
this number z in the constraints
okay so this is another stochastic
control problem that it has these two
variables t and z
so obviously if you put t to be zero and
z to be zero this is just the definition
of the relaxation
and hopefully now by looking at this
function and its behavior for all t
and c hopefully we can understand its
value at zero zero
so you can try to do dynamic programming
so this is you
open a book on stochastic control and
this is the first thing that one
do one does in this in this situation
you can try to do dynamic programming
and then try to write a pde or that is
satisfied by the
by by this function v okay so let me
skip the details
you can get this thing that is called
the hamilton jacobi bellman equation
that is that that basically rules the
behavior of this function v
and this is another pde that is not
linear it's a it's it's a it's a
complicated pd
and it looks like this
now hopefully that that pde will
turn into the pre-zpd under some change
of variables so that was our hope
so let's do this change of variables
let's consider that v
be written uh as the lagrange transform
of another function
phi and there are a bunch of other terms
that are that just compensates
that are not very important but the mo
the important part is this lagrange
this last transform
so if you do this change of variables
then
v satisfying this hamilton jacobi
bellman equation is equivalent to fee
satisfying the pericpd
and so based on that you can basically
find the relaxation so now once you have
this relation
then you can get the value of the
relaxation as the value of v at zero
zero by exploiting this that will be the
pcp
the per easy function so there is a
duality here between the simultaneous
jacobi belmont equation and the paris
epd
which reflects the duality between the
stochastic control problem
and the parisi formula
okay so here the main message is this
duality between the stochastic control
problem and
the very easy formula so these are equal
so these are as numbers as real
numbers these are equal and uh we've
exploited
this stochastic control formulation in
an algorithmic way so we got this
stochastic control formulation
uh from the design of an algorithm for
the question for the algorithmic design
question
of trying to trying to optimize the
value of the hamiltonian
and uh yeah so uh maybe this duality is
is not more deep more than that or we
can try to try to understand
this duality in order to say things that
we don't would not know how to say
about the parisi formula and just a
small remark here is that so
this to go back to this question of how
did the maximum change into an infinium
we're trying to maximize hamiltonian and
then
we end up with an expression of this the
limiting value of this
maximum to be an infimum over another
functional so how did the maximum turn
into an infinium now
we can answer that question and that
that that's because of duality
right so if you're trying to optimize
then hopefully you'll get something that
looks like a supremum
and that's what we that we've done here
so if you try to do an algorithm
consider this algorithmic approach that
tries to optimize
then you get a description that gives
you still a supreme because you're
trying to optimize you're trying to
maximize
then the infimum ends up being just the
dual of this other problem that was
that was to try to optimize right
so this is just a duality relationship
and uh yeah so some interest interesting
directions
after this is to try to get a physical
interpretation of this
extended uh variational principle and
since so
this for now we do not understand what
this extended uh principle corresponds
to in terms of properties of the
landscape of the
of the random energy function and uh
so yeah it would be an interesting thing
to try to understand in particular this
minimizer gamma that is not monotone
what's its
interpretation we do not know so
exploring this duality property and then
considering other models such as
beyond the pspin model or the sk model
that are perceptron k sats etc
the question of sampling is also an
interesting one so if instead of
considering optimization you can
consider
the problem at positive temperature and
uh
how can you produce a sample from the
gibbs measure at low temperature so we
do not know
and another extension we need to
consider sparse models instead of
having fully connected graphs you can
look at models that are
built on random regular graphs with say
constant degree can you for instance get
the value of min
bisection or max cut using this type of
approach yeah and thank you that's
all all right thank you very much
ahmed
um could i could i ask us to flash back
to the page where the duality is
is set up i just uh was uh i just wanted
to
no no the previous one uh which one
the the one where you're showing the
primal and the duel for the first time
uh this one yeah
[Music]
i guess i guess maybe i can ask a more
specific question i just wanted to see
how the choice of the set
capital fancy l arises um in the duality
yeah um so that arises from the desire
to
uh reduce this this uh duality gap so
you want this duality you want to kill
this duality gap
right so we want to optimize over the
largest possible class of functions that
you have
so the larger the class of functions
you're optimizing over hopefully the
smaller this duality gap is
right
i think i see okay
so now the question is just how large
can this space be in order for this
inequality to turn into equality and
that's how you get
the space of functions
i see okay so so in the primal there's
also optimization over
the choice of this gamma no so it's this
is a number this is that doesn't depend
on
gamma or anything
this this thing doesn't depend on gamma
the right hand side depends on gamma
because this is a lagrange multiplier
right
in the primal there is an equality
constraint that is expectation of u
squared equal one
yeah and this gamma is just lagrange
multiplier for
i see it has to be equal to one for each
time
okay so now you you put a dual parameter
for each time
so this is a function that can take any
value at each time right
now things in continuous time a little
bit
you cannot put uncountably many
multipliers so you have to choose a
function space right
sure
but conceptually you are putting a
lagrange parameter for every time
and this is your gamma i see okay
thanks okay by the way uh we don't have
any like a specific break time
question time built into the schedule uh
i do have a bunch of questions and we
can definitely stick around for
questions uh people need to go i just
want to point out that we have a social
hour to which you have to bring your own
drinks
and hors d'oeuvres sadly that's taking
place at 2 p.m pacific which is a little
over an hour from now
and the website for that is in the chat
i also put in the discord
uh but let's get back to the questions
i'm going to give you some questions
thanks again ahmed for your talk
some questions that have appeared from
the audience
yeah uh the first question is from um
jay mardia who asks what does this
algorithm look like for a simple
specific example
say the sharington kirkpatrick model is
there a simple description of the
updates
iterates yeah i mean it's not more
simple than this
it's just that's just that's how simple
it is but
where is it
they write it somewhere
yeah this is the iteration that's
alright no not that one
this is the iteration uh it's not
simpler than this so for the quadratic
case it reduces the gradient reduces to
just the
multiplying m by the matrix g right
but then this is as simple as it gets
now we have to choose
you have to choose the functions f in
the right way and the right way was
in a couple of slides after
is by exploiting this idea of orthogonal
updates
right so the functions f
that give that maps disease to the ends
are written in this way and you have to
choose these views
in the right way so here once you solve
the stochastic control problem so this
is a point that i didn't explain
once you solve the stochastic control
problem it tells you exactly what this
function should be
and those functions are basically the
second derivatives of the pre-z formula
of the the periz pde
solution so solve the pre-easy solution
that will give you a representation of
what this function
should be can i ask a related question i
i know i'm interjecting but
so there's a really naive algorithm
that says for a given point in the
interior of the cube
i calculate the i can calculate the
expected
energy of the uh
uh assuming that every s that the spins
are independent with those
magnetizations or marginals and then
inside the cube i could do gradient
descent and then i could do a
constrained gradient descent where
at each step i only do moves in the
hyper plane perpendicular to all my
previous moves
yeah um that's
not the algorithm you're describing
right that's an ev that's a very naive
algorithm
i'm just curious if we know how well
that algorithm works
um so let's see um so that's not the
algorithm i'm considering
but it's um it's in this family of
algorithms right so it looks
yeah it looks like a good idea so what
you can do is
um look at the iterates up to time l
or time j whatever and then
consider the next iterate by computing
the gradient at that point and then
projecting away
projecting it away from this linear span
of the previous iterates
exactly yeah so do we know anything
about what that achieves
uh so i think that would achieve the
value so that will also
get you no um
shaking i i don't know why i should
achieve the value
i mean so so yeah the intuition here is
that it's it's
attempts to satisfy these constraints of
orthogonal updates so
okay so it could be a good algorithm i
don't know how to analyze
it so that's yeah
uh yeah several more questions let me
take them slightly out of order we had a
question from
ashwin uh panangiadi who asked i may
have missed this actually i don't think
he did
but did we say what c of epsilon is the
number of iterations required for
approximate emissions passing to get
within one minus epsilon
right um that would be of roughly
speaking of order one over epsilon
squared
okay good answer perhaps i can give also
make a comment on chris
question why you know more naive
algorithm you know for any algorithm
in this class of amp you you can choose
this sequence of function in any way
this still goes more or less in the
direction of the gradient
and orthogonal to the previous iterates
and we can compute the value
and the point is that unless these
functions u are chosen in the optimal
way that is using the stochastic
optional control
the value i mean we have a tight
analysis of the value that you achieve
and the value is not the optimal value
right so i'll leave it at that
so but so in principle you could use
this machinery to calculate the values
that
that naive algorithm achieves uh
yeah i think in principle modeling work
yes
uh let me ask you a question from
another chris chris jones
i think of chicago uh chris asks um
if you fix any set of unit vectors s
do you think you can use this to
approximate the maximum of x transpose h
x uh over x in the set s
did you catch it uh yeah let me try to
parse this yes over
set us that's what what's the set as
it's any arbitrary sets
yeah so unfortunately the zoom does not
allow cut and paste but let me try to
retype the question just in case fix
any set of unit vectors
oh i can actually see the chat i can
actually see the chats use this to
approx i'll type it because it's hard
for people to understand
anyway if they're just listening x
transpose h hx
i don't know i don't know um
yeah uh i have no idea yeah we're
exploiting the structure of the cube
here
it depends if your set is weird then i
don't i don't expect like if your set is
really weird then why would
anything work i don't know
okay maybe a good open question to think
about during the week
um there's another question from uh
sikhi liu
uh she asks um question is max cut on
sparse d regular graphs
full rsp uh that's a good question
um it is believed to be so it is
believed to be the case
but so what does full rsv mean though
um so the way i defined it is that i
set up the breezy formula that is that
represents the maximum or
whatever the free energy the limit of
the free energy let's say
and then i defined full rsb to be the
property that the minimizer this
function that minimizes the previous
functional is strictly increasing
now in the sparse case such such
representations are not known
it is very difficult to come up with a
variational principle
that tells you for instance the number
or like that
characterizes the value of max cuts for
instance in a sparse random graph
there is a recent proposal in physics
but is extremely complicated
i don't understand it yet and then
extracting information formats would be
a difficult task
you can define full recipe in a
different way is in terms of the
structure of the landscape in terms of
how the solutions are organized
and that would still make sense to talk
about full rsv in
max cutter and sparse random graphs even
though we don't understand the prezi
formula
and it is believed that in this case
according to this definition of whole
rsv
yes it is believed that the problem is
for rsv
uh uh go ahead comment but on the hyper
graphs it's
probably non-rsv it if i understood
non-full rsv if i understood correctly
for your definition in the sense of
discontinuous support no
yeah so so right so hyper graphs when i
say you say hyper graphs
i think three spin or i think you know
yeah p spin right so max cut
is more related to sk closer to sk than
it is related to uh
yeah of course yeah
so go ahead the height the high level
the high level take home message here is
that
problems with full replica symmetry
breaking are easy to find near ground
states
uh yeah i mean you're i mean
since full rsv meant that that function
that the optimum was achieved by a
non-decreasing function
and the converse of that was that
there's an overlap gap
which we associate with hardness you're
basically saying that
full rsb equals easy uh yeah modulo
being able to find an algorithm
right that's kind of funny
uh i have a question maybe i'll actually
get at chris moore's earlier question
uh so for sharington kirkpatrick uh you
can code this
did somebody code it and run it yeah we
did um
andrea when is the paper going to show
up
any day
so we coded this yeah yeah we coded this
um
so there are difficulties in the
discretization yeah okay so it's a it's
a whole work
to try to code this up and uh you do get
consistent values experimental values
that are very consistent with the theory
so that will show up maybe in a couple
of days
i see and maybe uh are you able in a
future work to try chris's algorithm too
i mean compare them we can compare them
i don't think that's too difficult to
code yeah that one should be
we would be able to code that yeah mine
is much easier to code
right yeah and it's the uh is the
running time like i mean
is the a big factor in the running time
the one over epsilon squared
not really um not really not really you
can yeah for
maybe n equals a thousand to eight
thousand
that you can you can run the algorithm
in like less than a minute it's it's
it's fine
so cool sam you have a question
do you wanna just ask it vocally or yeah
um along a slightly different line how
much robustness could you expect from
from these algorithms in particular and
also from
maybe any algorithm achieving similar
guarantees if there are roadblocks to it
so by robustness
i mean um if i get if i allow an
adversary to
modify my input in some way modify the
the hamiltonian i'm working with or
maybe equivalently i give you a sample
from some distribution which is only
approximately uh you know a gui
matrix um you know it's close to
washington some distance but not
exactly the correct distribution to be
sampled from
yeah i mean as as long as as long as um
you have your if the distribution is not
the one that we
consider it here but it still produces
the same predictions then i would guess
you can still
use the algorithm but i guess robustness
here there is an adversary that tries to
correct that tries to screw you yeah
right so it tries to like get you to
your algorithm to fail and it would
guess this algorithm is brittle to that
i'm not i'm not sure but it doesn't i
don't i don't expect this algorithm to
be very very robust to this kind of
things
i i think due to oh
one simple robustness is that if you do
a perturbation that is small
in operator norm saying operator norm is
more than epsilon then
everything get you know it's continuous
gets better by epsilon
but beyond that if you do a large
operator non-perturbation i expect it to
become
a job sorry so if you if you do an
operator normal perturbation
the the this algorithm uh the value
doesn't change
easily and this algorithm also shouldn't
change
okay cool because it it's everything
but i have my phone here
you know for a second here but but there
is a
there is a chaos uh onset of chaos
happens pretty
quickly right so if you perturb just a
small fraction of entries
you in distribution will achieve the
same value but there will be an
up to nearly optimal solution of a com
essentially a completely different model
right one thing to pay attention here is
that the algorithm is not
okay why there is a completely different
solution because there is a solution
that is there are near optimal there are
you know delta times n above the global
optimum
and they are nearly orthogonal to the
global optimum
okay but here we are solving uh we don't
care about this delta times
and thing right even if we find one of
these
we are happy you just want to find one i
mean we are
in fact we don't claim that ever that we
find and i think
it's a good question whether we can find
you know approximation with epsilon
scaling like
you know n to the minus a inverse
polynomial
what is the inverse polynomial can we
find you know
near optimum within an error that is n
to the minus
you know one two three but you said the
running time
was was poly one over epsilon so that
what's the obstacle to doing that yeah
but that is for everything
for every fix the epsilon as n goes to
infinity
right so the order of limits is
important here
but that's that's important for the
analysis that you're able to give but
there's it
like is it believable that the same
algorithm
would you know run for longer would
produce uh
inverse polynomially good approximation
i don't know um
so you can ask whether you can get an
exact uh
optimum and uh we don't believe that
that's actually possible in polynomial
time
so that's the extreme version of your
question
yeah exactly exactly because of david
argument right if you want to
find a very precise optimum then you
really
need to be careful about checking every
entry of your metrics to within
30 digits decimal digits right
yeah i cannot think of such an algorithm
but perhaps you can
a related question here um is uh can you
produce not only
one optimum or one approximate optimizer
but many
can the same algorithm give you many
approximate optimizer to the same which
which have any inner products you want
so that you can modify this algorithm to
get you that so if you want sigma 1 and
sigma 2 to be approximate optimizers
and sigma 1 times sigma 2 should be 0.5
you can still do that with this
algorithm or modification of this
algorithm
so that will describe this tree so
you're just branching out in the tree
then you can bifurcate at any point you
want
and gets two trajectories that go to two
independent or
not independent but two approximate
global optima
and they have the inner product that you
want them to have which is the point at
which you bifurcate it in the tree
so actually we have two related
questions uh one from
siddhant and wave and one from ronan uh
i'll just read both of them it's okay
uh sit down because they're kind of
similar so steven's question was
depending on the random initialization
you get a
quote random output is there any reason
to believe the random outputs
distribution looks like a low
temperature gibbs distribution
and ronin asks a related question can
you say something about how the energy
of the point of the algorithm reaches is
distributed
on a scale that sees the difference
between one minus epsilon and one could
be the case that the algorithm actually
samples from the gibbs measure for some
temperature
which is slightly below the critical
temperature
let me try to absorb these questions um
so the first question is uh does it does
the
output looks like a sample from the
gibbs measure at some
some temperature so the epsilon is
is playing that role is playing the role
of beta
because so you're only trying so for any
fixed epsilon you're trying to get to a
level set
and uh you can see that's the the the
output of your algorithm is distributed
according to some not reveal
we don't know the distribution exactly
of the points in that level sets
but you can see roughly that there's a
correspondence between epsilon and beta
there the second question
was what is the distribution of the
energy that is achieved is that right
uh i think so let me dial it back by the
way does that answer your questions so
don't
yeah let's say so okay yeah ronan's
question was can you say something about
how the energy of the point the
algorithm reaches is distributed on a
scale that sees the difference between
one minus epsilon and
could be the case that the algorithm
actually samples from the gibbs measure
for some temperature which is slightly
below the critical temperature
so the distribution of the energy let's
see
no i don't have uh i mean i can tell you
the limits i mean at scale one it
converge to this number that is uh that
is given by the stochastic control
problem
but i don't have i don't have any
control over the fluctuations that
finance and
is that what you're asking so i mean at
scale one yes it converges to a delta
point which is
the number that is given by the
stochastic control problem
but for finite and i don't have
fluctuation results i don't know how
things fluctuate and stuff like that if
anything it wouldn't be
slightly below the critical temperature
it's probably going to be pretty close
to the
very temperature close to inverse
temperature close to infinity right
because you're nearly ground state
by the way i loved ronin if you're on
the call you can talk now apparently
yeah so i i thought you know maybe
something happens
and you it's actually an a more accurate
sample from
a gibbs measure for some suitably chosen
temperature
i know so we don't understand we don't
really understand sampler actually i
don't understand
sampling and how can you turn this
algorithm into a sampling procedure but
uh maybe i don't know andre
if you have something to say well i i
have just a comment okay first of all as
as uh david mentioned this at most is a
sample from
you know very low temperature right
uh not close to the critical temperature
because for example close to a critical
temperature as much
much higher energy much smaller
amistonium right
you know it's not to epsilon epsilon
would be a constant
and then you know so there is a sense in
which i think the samples or something
you can generalize this algorithm i
think at finite temperature
in a sense and there is a sense in which
this looks like
the gibbs measure but is a very weak
sense in the sense that
all quantities that concentrates in the
of the
measure that concentrates are reproduced
by the algorithm this is my conjecture
but not the quantities that do not
concentrate
in particular you see if you run two
copies of the algorithm
i think that the scalar product between
these two copies will concentrate
well if you sample two copies from the
gibbs measure the scalar product
the distribution of the scalar product
doesn't concentrate
so that is my contracture but but okay
here i'm just talking because we are
beating friends
is the intuition correct i mean i'm just
trying
to understand uh that like you
the tree is like branching
it like infinitely many different times
like
uh like continuously but every time it
it branches it only branches to like a
distribution with
finite entropy like you almost have like
if like the gibbs measure for low
temperature is concentrated on
like a finite number of choices and what
the
algorithm does is it like kind of
chooses from a subset of this that you
don't really
know how to characterize but
like it could be that there is some
branch
that it can't choose at all but
like you still get the same
concentration for all the quantities
is that a correct intuition
uh yeah i don't know if i understand my
intuition is that is it's
you know not not choosing necessarily
this each time there is a finite
number of branches that you should take
it's not taking necessarily those very
good ones
is taking something that is slightly
worse so in the end it ends up on a
much larger right like not not much much
worse but
like worse enough so that you you have
this
epsilon yeah and my sense is that it's
very difficult to avoid
that because of the cows basically right
because
imagine one other way of looking at it
is replace your
gibbs measure by the average of gibbs
measure where
i add you know epsilon
noise to each the coupling where epsilon
is some
n to the minus 0.01
then you know i think that
that uh you know this new gibbs measure
this method gives
measure uh it's very difficult
algorithmically to distinguish from the
original keeps measure
and yeah but you know if you sample from
this move that gives measure you
only catch some of the properties of the
original okay
thanks if i'm already unmuted can i ask
another small question
sorry right yeah of course
the choice the optimal choice of u sub t
is does it only depend on the martingale
capital m t at the same point in time
and on the energy
reached like the integral between zero
and t of
usds yeah so it uh it depends on the
on the final time of another process
that is not m that is not the
it's not the martingale it does depend
on the
at time t it depends only on this thing
that is x t
and x is another process that is defined
by an sde
so it's not really m it's uh something
else that is defined by an sde and only
depends on the depends on the final time
of data so like so so there's a way to
see this
choices like markov it doesn't depend
like on the past if you do the right
transformation
exactly but this this doesn't give
rise to a an algorithm
like on the level of amp which is also
markov
that like you you you only do the step
in a way that depends on the on on
little m
little z oh it does it does so at the
level so
not only this is markov in the limits
but it's also markov in the
at the level of the algorithm at finite
end so i wrote it this way but you can
write it in a more restrictive way
instead of writing that's u
j depends on the entire sequence of the
of the disease i can define another
auxiliary sequence that i can call x and
that x is basically the secretization of
the sd that i talked about that i didn't
write
and u will depend only on the final time
so u
j will depend only on x j so
it is also markov at the level of the
algorithm
but you have to add this extra vector
yeah you have to add an
extra auxiliary variable to the mix but
i didn't do that
just for the sake of presentation
right okay yeah and by the way you can
see that that's how we presented in the
paper so this is
if you look at the paper that's exactly
the way we present it
that's one more question uh from uh
federico ricci let me just see if i can
make it
so that he can talk
uh yeah can you
federico can you speak
can you hear me yes can you hear me yes
we can hear you
i don't know can you hear me
yes we can hear you
i'm sorry but i cannot hear you you hear
me
yes sir uh
maybe since we can talk it go ahead
i can't hear hmm
[Music]
you should be able to i mean i don't
know what the i don't know what to do
here
can you hear me we can't hear you yeah
yes
i'm sorry i don't know what happened
do you hear me he still hear you yeah
ah okay i don't see you
okay can you just take a shot and ask
this question
go ahead i don't know what happened okay
it was just a comment maybe to answer
the
the the chris question about
how difficult is to find the the ground
state of the sk model
uh if you run similar annealing
standards in anything
for long enough time you can reach in
the large
and limit number which is very close to
the
to the optimal value so even a very
simple algorithm
can grow very close to the to the
optimal value
and 10 to the minus 4 to the to the
optimal value
this can be also a partial answer on how
difficult is to
sample close to the to the ground state
similarly for long enough times we
expect to sample from the gibbs measure
so
maybe we can sample with that
but this is just numeric result so
no no proof of
any algorithmic uh threshold
i will try to reactivate my audio
otherwise i cannot
hear you anymore
so i just clarifying sorry i say andre
has a response
yeah i just wanted to comment on the
fact that yeah
that kneeling probably gets to you know
i mean this is why we started working
gets to the
very close to the ground state i don't
think it samples from the gibbs measure
in polynomial time
for the same chaos reason that that
we were mentioning before so in
particular if you do simulated annealing
to federico and compute the p of q the
distribution
of the overlap try to compute it i think
that
that becomes very difficult at low
temperature
so just to clarify and i guess you know
this
i'm using this to uh as a preview of the
social hour but uh
um but with more math i mean
not all algorithms in this family that
you're
talking about have this property but the
orthogonal update
it cannot take more than n steps right
we're living in a
in a in a world of of uh
dimension n right so
my other question is just have has this
orthogonal update idea
found its way to the people who work
empirically on neural networks and
things like that does it uh
has anyone found experimentally that it
accelerates things in
in other less principled areas
um not to my knowledge yeah i i don't
know
um maybe uh so lenka works on neural
networks and if you can tell us
something about this that's really
i mean i i think it's fine it's fine to
work on neural networks as long as you
can find useful applications to spin
glass theory
right yeah i don't know um yeah i have
no idea
i do not know
yeah we sure hope it will
right okay thank you everybody i think
that's a good time to stop
i guess we can just uh well we'll trust
simons to end this uh technological call
yeah we can everybody can applaud for
each other thank you for coming
and we'll see you tomorrow it starts at
9 15 pacific
and uh in 43 minutes or something we can
all
gather on gather gut town
okay see you tomorrow thank you thanks
ryan